es geht um Amerika warum die
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den USA und
China und wir denken ja immer noch dass
wir der Nabel der Welt sind wir Europäer
es geht um uns und die transatlantische
Einigkeit scheint wieder da zu sein nein
Amerika hat sich schon seit längerem
abgedriftet nach Asien die Hauptgefahr
ist China und man tut nur so viel wie
nötig bei der Ukraine um nicht wieder
als schwach dazustehen wie nach
Afghanistan damit die Alliierten in
Asien wissen wir sind für Euch da für
euch Japaner für euch Südkoreaner also
man tut es Nötigste nicht mehr um keine
Kriegspartei zu werden Russland ist
geschwächt ein seiner Schwächen
bewusstes Russland kam vielleicht dann
auch wieder einen Deal mit Amerika
machen der dealmaker ist im Petto Donald
Trump die werden einen Deal machen und
dann haben wir uns genug geschwächt und
werden zusehen müssen dass in Amerika
weiterhin gilt dieser bester
wer ist nicht glaubt Mohammed bin Salman
er war am besten und jetzt soll er
wieder unser sein weil er hilft und
genauso kann es mit Putin und Trump
gehen die zwei mögen sich ja das heißt
sie sagen Trump würde schneller den
Krieg beenden als beiden Deal machen
Putin und dir da habe ich keinen Zweifel
aber Trump hat ja ein wenig Probleme
weil unsere Kosten geht der dir nicht
nur auf Kosten der Ukraine
anzuerkennen das ist ja schon das
Problem ein Donald Trump muss man sagen
schlecht findet Demokratie
da ist meine Frage an Sie kann man
Donald Trump überhaupt noch als
Staatsmann legitim ernst nehmen wenn man
auf die letzte Wahl schaut wenn man auf
der Sturm aufs Kapitol schaut ist es
nicht wirklich keine demokratischen
Werte mehr gut was wir jetzt dazu sagen
ist zweitrangig was die Amerikaner sehen
ist wichtiger weil das wird in den zwei
sehr Haus bringen oder auch nicht und
ich sage Ihnen werfen Sie eine Münze da
haben sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit da
kommt wieder der wird jetzt
abgeschrieben aber der ist noch
weiterhin voll im Schwung und mein
gerade weil sie die ganzen Bereiche
genannt haben dann müsste ja jeder
erwarten in einer Ration Welt wo es
kognitiv noch überall funktioniert
müsste der schon lange weg sein nein
dieses Mal sind bei den Kongresswahlen
über die Hälfte also über 300 Leute
angetreten Designer Lüge glauben dass
der Präsident nicht im Amt legitim ist
absolut aber man hat ja gedacht die
re:publikaner holen noch mehr also es
war jetzt ja auch nicht dieser Rutsch
Alter die die deutschen Medien auch den
deutschen Medien ich glaube wer von
Amerika keine Ahnung hat hat nicht die
tiefrote Welle erwartet sie haben das
genauso erwartet wie es jetzt schauen
Sie was ich bei Pioneer mache ich ein
bisschen Button Werbung wir gab aber
Steiger schauen Sie sich die Szenarien
an Pioneer steckt Springer ja auch mit
drin dementsprechend
machen und dann haben Sie das schon
vorausgesagt bei Herrn Stein das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario dargelegt
dass wahrscheinlich das Abgeordnetenhaus
verloren geht und durch Trumps
Intervention im Senat eher eine
gemischte Bilanz haben wird und
wahrscheinlich für die Republikanerin
Senat vergeigt Herr Kreis wäre denn
besser volkswirtschaftlich für
Deutschland Trump oder beiden Trump viel
besser Trump hat ja damals ein
Außenminister gehabt der hat sogar den
russischen Orden gehabt also Trump würde
relativ schnell glaube ich tatsächlich
versuchen zumindest den Krieg zu beenden
jeder Tag Krieg ist für uns jeder Tag
sein Sanktion ist für uns für unsere
Mittelstand eine Katastrophe die
Amerikaner profitieren gerade zu davon
ja sie haben ihr Fracking Gas ist
endlich absetzen können also ich glaube
rein ökonomisch Trump war mir nie
besonders sympathisch aber rein
ökonomisch wäre Trump sehr viel besser
wir bräuchten ganz dringend Frieden und
die beiden Administrationen habe ich den
eintragstut alles
Protektionismus das bedeutet der er will
Amerika abschaffen das ist ja für
Deutschland eigentlich nicht abschaffen
sie recht aber das ist mein Punkt
volkswirtschaftlichen er will den
Protektionismus als den Freihandel das
gibt sich nicht viel mit beiden die
beiden Administrationen halt gegen China
Sanktionen gemacht hat es gegen Europa
Sanktionen gemacht bzw 100 Milliarden
Dollar Programm das gibt sich nicht viel
sagen der hat Bein hat gebellt nein
Trump hat gewählt und Wein hat einer
gewissen weil eben mit seinem Narzissmus
zu viel mit sich selber zu tun hat der
also beiden führt jetzt effektiv die
tramshagenda fort nur wir merken es noch
nicht die Franzosen haben es gemerkt
unser Wirtschaftsminister ist jetzt
aufgewacht und hat gemerkt dass es ein
frontaler griff auf unsere Wirtschaft
ist jetzt durch diesen Chip sein
Präsidenten Minister hat ja schon
gewarnt genau der hat gewarnt und jetzt
ist der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister
auch dahinter gekommen dass wir uns ein
bisschen besser aufstellen müssen aber
wir müssen das als Europäer machen denn
ich glaube das haben wir in Deutschland
noch nicht begriffen dass die Zeit der
Nationalismen vorbei sind dass wir uns
jetzt wirklich in diesem geökonomischen
Wettbewerb wo Freihandel nicht mehr das
Ziel ist sondern Wirtschaft eine Waffe
für den geostrategischen Zweck das wird
dann nur als europäische Einheit als
Block in diesem multipolaren Umwelt
bestehen können ich glaube da braucht es
vielleicht noch ein bisschen eine zweite
Amtszeit uns um endlich da mit ein paar
weiteren hinterschlägen auf den
Hinterkopf aufzubauen
noch eine ganz kurze Frage stellen zu
wie viel Prozent glauben Sie denn
persönlich weiß so Prognosen mag man
nicht gerne aber wie viel Prozent liegt
denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Trump
noch mal zurückkommen von der Amtszeit
erstmal die Frage wird er antreten
vielleicht wird er nächsten Dienstag
noch nicht sich bekennen da gibt es
Frage hat jetzt Runde Sandis
ganz guten Lauf der der super
abgeschnitten und Trumps Zeit ist
gemischt aber ich glaube da wird jetzt
zu sehr gehyped Runde Sand ist weiß dass
er ein Trump nicht vorbeikommt also wenn
der noch mal in den Ring geht und dann
wie gesagt ich habe sie dann schon
gesagt werfen Sie eine Münze aber es
gibt eben Sachen wie Corona wer hat denn
das auf dem Schirm wenn Corona nicht
gekommen wäre wäre Trump wiedergewählt
worden das hatte keiner auf dem Schirm
und das heißt es kann noch so viel
passieren in dieser Welt was wir alle
nicht sehen können aber unter diesen
jetzigen Umständen hat Trump sehr gute
Voraussetzungen noch mal ins Weiße Haus
zu kommen auch weil was viele Medien
nicht beachten derzeit auf
einzelstaatsebene Regeln gebogen werden
die nicht gebrochen werden können damit
das nächste mal rein aufgrund der
Sendezeit stoppen aber wenn man ihre
Ausführung noch mehr hören möchte sie
haben ja auch ein Buch geschrieben dass
von Herr korta hat mir schon
eingeblendet wie heißt denn ihr Buch für
transatlantische
Illusion wenn wir meinen dass die
Amerikaner weiterhin für unsere
Sicherheit sorgen dann haben wir eine
große Illusion sie haben nämlich sehr
viel mehr mit sich selber zu tun und
wenn sie sich noch für die Welt
interessieren dann mehr für China für
die Wachstumsregion Asien und nicht das
Museum